Here are our two answers. Great work if you found even one of those. For the
first one, we want to list all the factors of our radicand. We know 2 times 2
times 3 equals 12. Then we have 3 x's multiplied together. And 2 y's multiplied
together. We're taking the square root and the index is at 2 here. So we want
to find factors that repeat twice. We have two 2s, two x's and two y's, so we
can pull one 2 out, one x out and one y out. This 3 and this x are factors that
need to stay underneath the square root symbol, and it's because they are not
paired. This leaves us with our final answer, 2xy times the square root of 3x.
For the second one, we want to find factors that repeat three times, since our
index is a 3. We have three 3's and three c's, so we can pull out one 3 and one
c from our radical. These factors don't appear in a triple, so we have to leave
them inside of the cube root. We'll add 2a squared times c and our cube root.
This gives us our final result. Keep in mind that this 3 is the index on the
root, it's not the exponent of the c. So be careful when you're writing your
expressions.